and in this crucial mission there can no
longer be any argument for further delay
and as someone who passionately believed
that we had to go back to our European
friends to seek a better agreement I
must tell the house that with this new
deal the scope for future negotiation
for fruitful negotiation has run its
course they said they said he said they
said we couldn't change a comma of the
withdrawal agreement they said we
couldn't abolish the backstop mr.
speaker we've done both but it is now my
judgment that we have reached the best
possible solution so those who agree
like me the brexit must be delivered and
who like me prefer to avoid a no deal
outcome must abandon the delusion that
this house can delay again and I must
tell the house in all candor that there
is very little appetite among our
friends in the EU for this Breck
business to be protracted by one extra
day they have had three and a half years
of this debate it has distracted them
from their own projects and their own
ambitions and if there is one feeling if
there is one feeling that unites the
British public with a growing number of
officials in the EU it is a burning
desire to get brexit done
and I must tell the house again in all
candor that whatever letters they may
seek to enforce the government seek to
force the government to write it cannot
change my judgment the further delay is
pointless expensive and deeply corrosive
of public trust people simply will not
understand how politicians can say with
one breath that they want delay to avoid
No Deal
and then with the next breath that they
still want delay when a great deal is
that
now is the time mr. speaker to get this
thing done and I say to all members let
us come together to end let us come
together as Democrats to end this
debilitating feud let us come together
as Democrats to get behind this deal the
one proposition that fulfills the
verdict of the majority but which also
allows us to bring together the two
halves of our hearts to bring together
the two halves of our nation let's speak
now both for the 52 and for the 48 let's
go this country let's go for a deal that
can heal this country and can allow us
all to express our legitimate desires
for the deepest possible friendship and
partnership with our neighbors a deal
that allows us to create a shared
destiny with them and a deal that also a
deal that also allows us to express our
confidence in our own democratic
institutions to make our own laws to
determine our own future to believe in
ourselves
once again as an open generous global
outward-looking free-trading
United Kingdom that is the prospect that
is the prospect of this deal offers our
country it is a great prospect and a
great deal and I commend it to the HUS
[Applause]
[Music]